Okay, here's probably a good one.
Can you tell Spot what to do?
So, yes, Spot does not have a mind of its own.
You have a controller where you can directly command Spot,...
...kind of like an Xbox controller...
...or you can program it to do an autonomous mission.
But all of these things, you are setting up and defining for Spot.
Can I drive the robot into or over a trash can or a classmate?
It's a great question...
...and we try to bake in obstacle avoidance into our robots...
...from a software and vision perspective.
You know, if a human lays down on the floor and you're not very big,...
...it might think you're a step that it could walk over.
So, I wouldn't say to try that.
Does Spot have a favorite color?
Well, I would like to think that it's yellow,...
...but since robots can't think, I'm just going to decide for it.
Yes, it's yellow.